if you've been uh listening to the show
for a while you know that i have been a
longtime skeptic of the pharmaceutical
industry now of course pretty much
everyone claims to be a skeptic of the
pharmaceutical industry people on the
left are predisposed you would think
anyway to hate big pharma because it's a
multi-billion dollar industry
which you can put the word big in front
of and that means that it's evil many
people on the right have become even
more critical of big pharma in the last
few years especially because of how it
has pushed the coveted vaccines a push
that now by the way as of a few weeks
ago
officially includes children as young as
six months old so if you want to bring
your baby in for a covet vaccine you can
now do that though i certainly wouldn't
recommend it and yet
a large preponderance of both groups
even while usually assuming a kind of
skeptical posture towards this industry
will let big pharma entirely off the
hook
when it comes to psychiatric drugs
as of 2021 nearly 65 million americans
had been prescribed at least one
psychiatric drug think about that for a
second 65 million americans
just five years before that the number
was 40 million 40 million was already
sky high
in five years it's gone up over 20
million
20 percent of the country is on
medication for mental illness and that
number is climbing by multiple
percentage points every year meanwhile
our our health authorities our so-called
health authorities tell us that the real
crisis is untreated read
non-drugged unprescribed mental illness
so they see the 65 million americans on
psychotropic drugs for mental illness
and they insist that the number is far
too low we actually need to get it much
higher should be 100 million should be
150 it should be everybody
they and i'm not joking about that
either because the dsm expands the
diagnostical manual of mental disorders
expands with each new addition
until every single human emotion
personality trait uh proclivity impulse
has become a mental illness and we're
already at the point with the latest dsm
where you can open it up and find
probably at least five or ten mental
illnesses that would apply to you
so
they
the health establishment the medical
establishment they demand that uh that
more and more mentally ill quote unquote
people most of them suffering from
things like depression or anxiety or
adhd be identified and drugged
immediately
never mind the significant and often
dangerous side effects of these drugs
never mind that we're altering people's
brains and mass
never mind that we're diagnosing
conditions that we barely understand and
drugging them based on poorly supported
and sometimes demonstrably false medical
theories never mind all that
just keep the drugs
and most importantly the money flowing
this is what big pharma along with
doctors and psychiatrists have been
doing
and many people on both the left and
right who are normally quite eager to
criticize the medical establishment fall
silent
as that same medical establishment
declares millions upon millions of
americans
mentally ill so mentally ill that they
need psychotropic drugs in order to
function
on this point
many of our big pharma critics are
willing to simply take big pharma's word
for it well they say we're all mentally
ill so i guess we are
they might lie about everything else
these uh selective critics will say but
they would never lie about the best
treatment for depression well they would
never lie about that
quite an odd claim when you think about
it
and on the subject of depression uh the
quote mental illness that accounts for a
large portion of that 65 million figure
it's been taken as gospel for many years
that drugs are necessary to treat it
because
the condition is caused by a
quote-unquote chemical imbalance in the
brain
this is an idea that people have
absorbed from the culture and especially
from propaganda from the drug companies
you know it's not it didn't it did this
didn't end up out there by accident
that's what the drug companies want you
to believe
it's a chemical imbalance so we'll give
you a little chemical and a pill and
we'll fix it right up for you
and it's a doctrine that is jealously
guarded and defended
i know from experience that if you
question it
if you dare suggest
that maybe there's more to it than a
chemical imbalance you will be viciously
attacked for your heresy
people like the chemical imbalance idea
because it seems simple and because it
uh totally absolves the individual from
the responsibility to do anything to
help solve their own mental troubles it
takes things like you know lifestyle
diet etc takes that out of the equation
entirely
it gives a simple cause promises a
simple solution and one that requires
almost no work on the part of the
individual just take the pill that's it
take the pill and everything will be
better
that's big pharma's motto take the pill
take the shot everything will be fine
you solve your depression with a magic
pill
big pharma makes billions win-win for
everybody right
well wrong
the problem with the chemical imbalance
idea
the one that has led to millions of
people being put on psychiatric drugs
the one that has put billions and
billions hundreds of billions into the
pockets of big pharma the problem with
that idea
is that there was never any evidence to
support it it's a marketing slogan it's
not a medical diagnosis
and a study that was just released this
week this is a truly i don't use this
phrase very often in a non-ironic way
but it is a bombshell study reported by
the guardian
finally blows the lid off of the whole
scam here's the headline
little evidence that chemical imbalance
causes depression ucl scientists find
reading now from the study it says
scientists have called into question the
widespread use of antidepressants after
a major review found no clear evidence
that low serotonin levels are
responsible for depression
prescriptions for antidepressants have
risen dramatically since the 1990s with
one in six adults and two percent of
teenagers in england now being
prescribed them millions more people
around the world regularly use
antidepressants quote many people take
antipress antidepressants because
they've been led to believe their
depression has a biochemical cause but
this new research suggests that this
belief is not grounded in evidence this
according to the study's lead author
joanne moncrief a professor of
psychiatry university college london and
consultant psychiatrist at northeast
london nhs foundation trust quoted is
always difficult to prove a negative but
i think we can safely say that after a
vast amount of research conducted over
several decades there is no convincing
evidence that depression is caused by
serotonin abnormalities particularly by
lower levels or reduced activity of
serotonin thousands of people suffer
from side effects of antidepressants
including the severe withdrawal effects
that can occur when people try to stop
them top stop taking them yet
prescription rates continue to rise we
believe this situation has been driven
partly by the false belief
that depression is due to a chemical
imbalance it is high time to inform the
public that this belief is not grounded
in science
so it would seem that big pharma has
made billions of dollars fixing a
problem that does not exist
depression certainly exists don't get me
wrong
but depression caused by a chemical
imbalance is a myth
and it is a mythical creation
that the antidepressants are meant to
fix
it's something the pharmaceutical
companies have made up a problem they
made up and then gave us the cure for
reading more from this report which is
just more and more damning for the
pharmaceutical industry as you go along
it says in the new analysis researchers
said 85 to 90 of the public believes
depression is caused by low serotonin or
a chemical imbalance
most antidepressants are selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors originally
said to work by corrupt correcting
abnormally low serotonin levels
the review published in the journal
molecular psychiatry looked at studies
examining serotonin and depression
involving tens of thousands of people
one of the findings was that research
comparing levels of serotonin and its
breakdown products in the blood or brain
fluids did not discover any difference
between people diagnosed with depression
and healthy people the authors also
looked at studies where serotonin levels
were artificially lowered in hundreds of
people and concluded that lowering
serotonin in this way did not produce
depression in hundreds of healthy
volunteers other studies looked at the
effects of stressful life events and
found that the more stressful life
events a person has experienced the more
likely they were to be depressed
showing the importance of external
events
who would have thought
apparently external events you know the
things that happened to us in our lives
the events that we're a part of the
things that we suffer from the things
that we encounter like all of that your
everyday life these have a deep and
lasting effect on our moods and our
emotions and our mental states
now of course even with this study or
rather without this study debunking the
chemical imbalance theory which was
never really a theory actually but more
of an unproven and arbitrary guess
but before the study was was even
published it was already obvious
that the chemical imbalance idea made no
sense for one thing in order to diagnose
an imbalance we must first have some
idea
of what the correct balance is supposed
to be and yet none i would wager to say
none of the 90 of the public who
believes in the chemical imbalance can
articulately explain what sort of
balance we're supposed to have in our
brains oh there's a chemical imbalance
oh really what so what's the
what's what what is our balance supposed
to be exactly what's like the ideal
balance well i don't know we just i just
know that it's imbalance
and even if we did know what sort of
balance we're supposed to have how
exactly do they diagnose the imbalance i
mean do they diagnose it at all
out of all the millions of people
prescribed antidepressants were any of
them given a brain scan or a blood test
or any other sort of physical medical
test to confirm that this imbalance
existed before it was treated
like these are drugs that are supposed
to treat a physical problem did they
ever do anything to confirm the
existence of the physical problem inside
the individual before giving them the
drugs for it
no
never
well that's odd
if depression is simply biochemical in
origin then why isn't it diagnosed on a
biochemical basis
if it's a simple physical ailment why
isn't it confirmed physically
before being treated as if it's simply
physical
these are the kinds of questions we
could have been asking all along but
hardly anyone ever did
i want to read one last part of this
report because it's important it says
according to the research there is also
evidence from other studies that
antidepressants may actually induce
induce low serotonin in the long term
it may actually create the problem it's
supposed to fix
quote our view is that patients should
not be told that oppression is caused by
low serotonin or by chemical imbalance
they should not be led to believe that
antidepressants work by targeting these
unproven abnormalities quote we do not
understand we do not understand what
antidepressants are doing to the brain
exactly and giving people this sort of
misinformation prevents them from making
an informed decision about whether to
take anti-presence or not
they don't understand exactly what these
drugs are doing to the body
but they prescribe them anyway that's
another thing that i've been saying for
years
the people giving these drugs out don't
actually know exactly what they do
because the brain the human brain's a
complicated place
you know
putting people on drugs putting things
into people's bodies without really
knowing what's what it's going to do
there seems to be a lot of that sort of
thing going around these days
a lot of it
and this sort of half-blind approach is
particularly terrifying as it relates to
the brain
because the brain again is still a
mystery to us in many ways and yet drug
companies are tinkering with it messing
with our minds without really knowing
whether what they're doing will work or
or how it's working if it does work or
what the long-term or even short-term
effects will be
one of the side effects of of many
psychiatric drugs is suicidal thoughts
which is morbidly ironic because again
that's the problem that they're supposed
to help treat and yet they can cause
that problem apparently so these are
drugs which according to the companies
that produce them may cause you to think
certain thoughts they may put thoughts
into your head
self-destructive dangerous thoughts
that fact alone should give us pause
now does this mean that there is no
physical aspect to depression of course
not i mean we're physical beings our
brains are physical
there's going to be a significant
physical element to the problem i mean
to any problem that we suffer from
including mental problems by definition
but it's also
multifaceted and complicated depression
is a feeling of emptiness despair
hopelessness meaninglessness
if a person is feeling that way it's
almost always impossible to start to
discern one simple cause
that's what the drug companies sell
one simple cause but it's never that
simple
there are internal and external factors
all tracing back to the universal human
condition the fact that we are mortal
beings living in a world of constant
pain and suffering and death and misery
with lots of aimlessness and boredom in
between
yeah the depressed person is is not
crazy or sick
because they recognize this fact about
life
in fact here's here's the here's the uh
the point that we always miss in this
discussion there are a lot actually of
very good reasons
to feel pretty bad
living as just a human being in the
world world could be a really tough
place
it doesn't mean that we should feel bad
it doesn't mean that if someone does
feel bad we should just leave them to
their misery
but the point is that these feelings are
not crazy they're not delusional
there's there's there are reasons for
them
and person who's a person who's overcome
with these feelings their problem is
is that they are not able to
sufficiently cope
with
our condition as human beings in this
world
they're not able to find meaning and
hope and joy in spite of
all the terrible things that come with
being a human being in the world
the way to treat the depression is to
help them cope which will involve
everything from better lifestyle choices
to diet and exercise getting outside on
a sunny day and taking a walk like
things like that even really really
simple things
it's not the be-all and end-all but
things like that
in some cases there may still be need
for for drugs temporarily but they're
going to be a band-aid not a cure
you can't cure despair with a pill
despite what the drug companies have
told us
and the drug companies have told us a
lot of lies they have
especially recently
and it's quite a statement but this
might be the biggest one yet
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
spotify or wherever you get your podcast
you